Australia's most famous maths teacher
visited karingal high school today Eddie
Wu has become an internet sensation with
his flipped cloths room approach and is
known to students worldwide as Mr Wu
tube
love it or hate it maths might divide
students at school but for Eddie Wu it
is a powerful tool if you had to take a
guess do you think there's like hundreds
or maybe 20 or what would you estimate
yeah interesting as the leader of the
mathematics growth team Eddie visited
karingal high school today giving
students an interactive Workshop
experience
the program is based in schools for two
years at a time to support the
curriculum across New South Wales it's
like I knew he was like a very skilled
math teacher so I was excited to have
him come over to our school and so far
I've been enjoying the session I've
learned quite a few new things since
2012 Wu has been filming YouTube videos
on his successful Channel woo tube
boasting 1.7 million subscribers it's
always a bit strange to me that lots of
people are following me on a place like
YouTube because it's not like I am a
professional YouTuber I'm a teacher and
what you can see on my channel are
really just my everyday classroom
lessons but the math gurus videos
demonstrate the flipped classroom idea
where students can view classroom
explanations from home give students the
choice in the autonomy to drive some of
their own learning you know they don't
have to necessarily wait for me they
might say oh I really get this video I
can go to the next one or the next one
and it it's not only students who
benefit from Wu's approach one of the
delightful surprises for me is that I
never intended for teachers to be the
main audience of the videos that I
produce it's the second time anywhere
has been at karingal high school and
it's his hope he will continue
connecting with students across Regional
New South Wales Mala summer seven years